Hi, welcome back.
In this class, we'll be learning some basics of procedural content generation in Unreal
Engine to support our world-building workflows.
There are a few settings in our project we need to take care of before starting to work
with PCGs, so let's jump for a moment in the engine and review them one by one.
Back in our project, we want to go under Edit and Plugins.
Then in the search bar, type Procedural.
And specifically, these three plugins should be activated.
So Procedural Content Generation Framework, Content Generation Framework External Data
Interrupt, and Content Generation Framework Geometry Script Interrupt.
Besides that, you also want to make sure that Procedural Mesh Component is activated.
Those four plugins should be already activated in this specific project, but if they're not,
make sure to activate them manually yourself and then restart the engine.
Alright, once your engine is wired up again and running, we can close this window.
And then if you wanted to get started with your PCGs, you would first need to create
a PCG Graph Asset.
So you would need to right-click on the Content Browser, go under PCG, and then create a PCG
Graph.
An Unreal Engine here gives you the option to start from a template, or if you prefer,
you can also create an empty graph.
Now unfortunately today, we're not going to build a whole PCG Graph from scratch.
This series of lessons only aims to give you an overview of these workflows.
But you can find courses on our platform that you can just follow to dive deeper into PCGs.
So let's go back to the slides and we will take a look at the further steps we will need
to take when getting started with PCGs.
Alright, once your PCG asset has been created, you want to drag it in your scene and adjust
the size of it as you need it.
Later on, you want to open up your PCG Graph Asset and start out by defining the way you'd
like to populate your map, either by spawning these meshes on your terrain or landscape
using a surface sampler or through a spline using a spline sampler, for example.
After that, you want to add a few nodes to assess how the ISM or instance aesthetic meshes
are going to be placed into your map.
And that's what the transform points would be for.
So usually the nodes expressing which meshes will be spawned are at the end of the graph.
And it's useful as you move along in the development of a PCG Graph to just enable debug mode by
pressing D on a node or just double-clicking on it to inspect it and view it in the Data
Viewport.
This will display little squares as preview meshes and will give you an overview of where
you're at in the development of your PCG.
OK, let's jump into the engine and see a complete example of a PCG using a surface sampler.
You're totally welcome to use an Examine this graph as a starting point to create your own
or just learn from it.
Let's go.
Alright, so if we pan a little bit around, we can find up here this big purple cube encompassing
most of the trees down here in our set.
And if we click on it, we will find out that this is actually a PCG Graph.
And once we have it selected in our Outliner, we can go down here into the Details panel
and if we scroll down, we will find the graph that is connected to this asset.
So let's double-click on it to open it up.
Alright, so if we zoom into this graph, we can see that we have one main input point,
which comes from the landscape.
And then we have five different set of nodes or different static meshes.
The plants and the rocks, the small bushes, the many trees, the large trees and the large
rocks.
This different set of nodes will basically be spawning different meshes.
We're using surface samplers to generate a point cloud that follows the topology of
the input surface, in this case the landscape.
And if we click on the surface sampler, we will get access to a few settings, especially
the points per square meters.
With this setting specifically, we can control the density of the point distribution.
So if we click on the node and then press A, we can start inspecting it and it will
be displayed in the data view board.
These little cubes are actually just temporary preview meshes.
So if I, for example, were to increase the points per square to something like 26, you
will see that the density of these points will highly increase.
So I'm just going to control Z to keep it to its original value.
Now after the surface sampler, we have a transform points nodes.
And transform points simply add spatial transformations to the point data we output from the surface
sampler.
They basically let us define minimum and maximum position, rotation and scale values of our
points and add some variation to them.
After that, we have a union and difference set of nodes.
Now the difference node performs a subtraction on the sample points, removing specific ones
from the source that fall within the bounds of that difference.
For now, there is nothing connected to the difference input.
So if we double click on this node, we will see that nothing is actually happening in
the view board.
And that's because we're actually not subtracting anything to it.
If we click on the difference node, we will see in the setting that the density function
will be set to binary.
It's important to leave it like that because this way we will be treating all the points
as either present, so once, or absent, zeros, and get very predictable results or very predictable
cuts.
We usually use a union node before the difference node to resolve multiple point sources into
a single merged point cloud before performing a subtraction operation with a difference.
Now this last node over here is a static mesh spawner.
So if you simply right click in the graph and then add a static mesh spawner, you will
see that it will have the same look and input and outputs.
And if you press F2 or right click on it and then rename, you will be able to rename it
large rocks.
So this is how this node was created.
Static mesh spawners basically just spawn static meshes positioned based on whatever
we expressed in the nodes before it.
And we can define the meshes we want to spawn through the static mesh spawner down here
in the details under mesh entries.
We would need to add one more, then open up the index, the descriptor, and then down here
we would be able to input our static meshes.
I will just go on and delete it.
Now if I pan down here in the graph, you will find this self pruning node.
A self pruning node will basically remove any overlapping points from a point cloud
based on their bounds.
So it basically checks all the points for self intersection and an emulates those conflicting
with each other.
In this specific setup down here, we could actually bypass the union and different nodes
as right now we're basically subtracting the same points from each other, resulting
in zero points.
So if I double click on the difference, you will see that our view board will be completely
empty and we wouldn't have any preview meshes.
But if we press Alt on our keyboard and then click on the input pin of large trees to disconnect
it, and then connect the self pruning output directly to large trees, and then inspect
these large trees node, some large trees would actually end up being spawned.
Alright, so you can take a look at this further, but for now we'll just go back to the slides
and check out a different type of PCG workflow.
There is one thing to keep in mind, even though PCG graphs are optimized and using mesh instancing,
they do have limitations and your performance will be impacted if you add too many items
to them, especially if those static meshes are too heavy.
They're not invincible.
So let's acknowledge that when creating an environment, there won't be always one tool
fitting all our needs.
And in this course, we're presenting you with multiple options to allow you to pick and
choose the ones that best aligns with your goals.
So let's go back into Unreal and check out a different PCG setup.
Alright, let's go back to our map.
And then if I pen around here, I will find a different PCG cube.
So let's select it in our map.
And then down here on the right in the details panel, we'll get access to the graph.
So let's double click to open it up.
Alright, we can immediately see that this graph is a little different from the one of
the PCG sample 01.
Simply because it doesn't generate a point cloud from a landscape, but from spline data.
So simply we can see that we are defining the spline that we will be sampling through
an actor selection tag that is specified here in the details.
The first spline data is sampled from a spline with a tag assigned to it of test spline.
And the second spline data is taken from a spline or an actor with the path tag assigned
to it.
So let's go briefly to our map and then zoom into this PCG graph.
We can see that we actually do have two splines here.
One is outlining the trees and the other one is like a path cutting through them.
So let's select our first spline here that is encompassing the trees.
It's going to be a little bit tricky at first.
You will be selecting the landscape, but finally you will succeed and select the correct spline.
So this is BP underscore samspline.
And if I search down here in the details for tag, I can see that I do have a tag assigned
to it and it is test spline.
If I click on BP path spline in the outliner, I will be able to select the path going to
the trees.
And down here in the details, you will see that the tag assigned to it is path.
So that's how the PCG graph is getting that spline data.
After that, we're using the spline samplers to generate a point cloud that follows the
splines.
And we're using two because with one, we're defining the area encompassing the spline.
And the other one, if we zoom into it like this, it's a little bit hard to see, but I
hope you will be able to see it in the video.
We're basically defining the outline of the spline.
And then we're subtracting the two, thus limiting the spawn trees to be only within the spline.
We're self-rooting to make sure that there are no overlapping trees.
And then we're moving them a bit around and scaling them down.
Then on this other set of notes below, we're getting the spline data from the path.
We're sampling the point cloud along the spline.
We're using a bounce modifier, which allows us to explicitly modify the extent of the
points in our point cloud, which in this case, we're basically using this to create a larger
exclusion zone around our points, larger than our spline path.
And then we're basically subtracting this from the areas of the trees.
And thus we're creating a path that is cutting to the trees.
And this is easier to see in our map.
So if I go back to our map, you can see here that if I start moving these points around
with my spline selected, I will be able to define how this path or road will be going
through the trees.
And if I were to be painting the terrain here and adding a different materials like some
rocks or pebbles, it would really look as if a road will be cutting through this forest.
Now let's select this other spline over here.
And if I move the points of the spline here, you can see that the trees will always fall
within the spline area.
But if I increase the surface area of the spline, more trees will be spawned.
And if I just reduce it, less trees will be spawned.
All right, now that we have an overview on different PCG workflows, let's go back to
our slides to conclude this video.
So that was it for this class, but you can find some additional documentation at this
link if you're interested in further expanding your knowledge in PCGs.
I would also encourage you to take a look at our courses focused on procedural content
generation on our platform, because they will walk you through the development of PCGs.
Thanks for sticking around, and in the upcoming lesson, we will be looking into Blueprint
and Modeling Tools in Unreal Engine.
I'll see you there.